there's smoke coming out of the
kitchenaid i'm getting a little bit of a
workout here
it's so fun it's like cutting into a
dough pillow
okay
[Music]
hey guys i'm alvin welcome back to
tasties making it big where we make huge
versions of some of america's most
beloved foods things have changed a
little bit we're in a different time
different place different circumstances
but one thing that hasn't changed is
tasty's love for giant foods today we
are gonna be making a huge mac and
cheese why i love mac and cheese i love
the pasta i love the amount of cheese
that goes into it i think it's delicious
and i think it's gonna be really fun
just make a giant version of it so let's
get started
okay so for mac and cheese the first
thing i want to do is make fresh pasta
all right i have my uh trusty friend
here i'm gonna go in with i should have
put it in the bowl first but that's okay
and about one two three four five six
seven a lot of eggs
and some salt and instead of doing this
all by hand like a true pasta maker
would i'm gonna use the power of
technology with my friend todd here
oh
that spilled flour everywhere yet tod's
is going to do his thing for the next
five ten minutes or so and hopefully he
doesn't get too tired out but i'm just
gonna sit back and wash while he does
all the work so see you guys in a little
bit
there's smoke
coming out of the kitchenaid i don't
know if you can tell but you could buy
to overwork todd a little too hard
thanks dude you've done good today
served your purpose we could take it to
the the kitchenaid graveyard sad music
place
[Music]
pouring out for
the homie todd
i would say todd probably got me 80 90
of the way there it's up to me to carry
the burden to finish the rest this look
kind of not as smooth as i would have
liked but to be honest guys i'm kind of
weak right now i haven't gone in the gym
in a very long time i'm just gonna let
this rest hopefully the resting relaxes
the dough all right we're gonna get you
in here
good job dude time for this guy to take
a nap
[Music]
okay so i made two more doughs while the
first one is resting
all right you had a nap come out now
oh shape them up a little bit okay i
want to cut this guy into eight pieces
so that's four and then two good math
alvin
[Music]
oh that's satisfying like cutting into a
dough pillow this will be over here it's
like a scone this is pretty cool all
right let's get
this guy into a rough shape for the
pasta machine table is shaking that's
okay i'm gonna roll it in this pasta
machine just to make sure that we're
good
and the handle came out that's fine can
we go in already yes we can
come on you can do it yeah
not bad for one we're gonna do one more
i think you're making a couple of fun
pasta shapes and she's a ruler and seven
inches by four inches should be good
the handle really just doesn't like
being in the pasta machine today give it
a nice flare now it's looking good okay
so i'm actually gonna make little bow
ties i don't know i really like the bow
tie shape
little bow tie or a big bow tie i guess
i'm gonna keep making these bow ties for
a while until i have a lot excuse me
while i spend some private time making
this pasta
[Music]
okay pasta is all done uh time to make
the cheese sauce first we're gonna start
with four sticks of butter
a lot of butter this is gonna be kind of
like not really a bechamel but a cheese
sauce that involves making a roofer so
i'm gonna get this butter melted but i
take a while okay so the butter is
melted time for the flour
that's a lot of flour usually you know
rose like one tablespoon of flour to one
tablespoon of butter we put like four
sticks of butter that's 32 times what a
usual amount for this kind of thing
would be i think it's time to season
this so we have garlic powder onion
powder pepper mustard powder salt and
some paprika season your stuff kids
makes a big difference add some milk
oh that's a spill you gotta whisk really
hard no lumps
i'm getting a little bit of a workout
here oh okay it's getting thick more
milk i don't think i've ever made this
much sauce before it's kind of cool and
the funny thing is that this isn't even
all the sauce i'm gonna have to do this
again because this is the biggest pot
that we could cook it in so the actual
amount of sauce is going to be double
what we have here final batch
please fit okay there's a lot of sauce
it's gonna take a long time to cook so
i'm gonna put a lid on it and i'm gonna
let this guy hang out and cook with the
lid cracked see you in a bit
please
okay it's been a while and it's been
boiling and it got really thick and nice
which is fantastic and now probably one
of my favorite parts about making cheese
sauce is the cheese so i want to take
this off the heat shredded cheddar a lot
of it
i want to take this slow it smells
amazing
let's get the rest of it in there please
be enough room cheese you melt right
once you melt all the volume disappears
that's how science works right wow
this is wild i'm gonna go back to the
whisk slow and steady wins the race is
what a loser would say but in this case
they're correct i think we are pretty
much there i do want to taste it though
[Music]
that's so good
i'll be right back i'm gonna go cook
some noodles
okay so we're back in the tasty kitchen
and we have a huge pot of water boiling
all of our bow ties have been made have
been drying over here so i think it's
time to give them a nice little hot tub
you go in make sure you don't stick to
the bottom put on one of these go to the
prom with a wedding it's pretty good
see you guys in a bit why babies hit
these big bow ties
okay so these guys have been in for
about 10 minutes now i think it's time
to come out so we're gonna put them in
some cold water make sure they don't
stick to each other and dry out
here's guy number one
they've maintained the bow tie structure
which makes you really happy oh yeah i'm
gonna have to get out of here soon my
right arm might fall off whoa all right
i have a whole lot more pasta to cook so
i'll be standing here switching between
my arms so they don't fall off and after
that i think it's gonna be time to build
the mac and cheese so excuse me i have
some bow ties to cook
okay so i think we're ready to assemble
a ton of pasta lots and lots of cheese i
think this is like 10 liters of a cheese
sauce and i think the best way to go
about this is to probably layer it to
first start off i'm going to get some of
this cheese sauce and lay it down no
questions about it the cheesiest thing i
have ever done
layered down some
noodles
one
this might take a while
okay and then some more cheese sauce
let's get rid of this dude first some
cheddar
it's so fun and then a little bit of
matz
then another layer of pasta okay let's
do some more cheese colby jack
in there put some more this moss let's
do some gouda like a kid in a candy
store
it's pretty good okay next layer
i got some on my neck hold on
i knew that was gonna happen
then we will do some gruyere
wow that's a lot of cheese and the rest
of the gouda this is so much cheese this
is the size of the one that we made and
this is the size of a regular bow tie
it's probably like 20 times the size
let's knock out the cheddar on this
layer huh actually i'll save some of you
for the top okay i think this might be
the final layer wow there's still a lot
of stuff in there last bit
cheesy saucy goodness smooth it out hold
those cracks last but not least some
fresh mozzarella for that nice
cheesiness i might have put too much
cheese or maybe there's no such thing
you know put some browning on top last
bit of cheddar i think that's it
i don't really know how heavy this is
oh okay i want to put this on a cart and
we're gonna go bake this
all right come on little dude
it's time to go in the oven i feel like
i'm dragging my kid to school
i don't have any kids but if i did
this is how i would drag them
maybe i shouldn't say that let's get you
into the oven little boy
oh that sounded weird oh boy
[Music]
all right
wow it's like bending the rack okay
goodbye dude
see this guy
probably baked for at least an hour or
so
but
yeah
the cheese is getting really melty as
you can see and to make sure that this
cheese gets a nice and bubbly top we're
going to
broil it i'll babysit it make sure that
it doesn't burn we'll see how it goes
oh boy
oh wow this is this looks amazing
this is a big one
school's over i'm dragging my kid back
home
come on little guy
let's go
so we're back the cheese is here it
smells amazing and the finish i'm going
to garnish with sprinkle of chives whoa
that makes it look very expensive also
adds a nice sort of oniony taste to the
cheese which will be really good
okay this is the moment of the troop the
big
big cheese pool there's no time like now
for a cheese pull alvinzo 20 20. oh man
oh
man
look at this beautiful deliciousness
ready for it i think it's
a little hot
let's go with the ladle screw this
little spoon
this is gonna be a huge scoop
oh yeah
[Music]
all right let's give myself some mac and
cheese
oh
okay that's pretty good
finish it off
i'm really excited to eat this i think
it's gonna be awesome yeah i'm just
gonna eat so you guys have to watch me
do that
oh man that was so good oh my god it's
creamy it's cheesy super seasoned well
wow i'm gonna eat a lot of this okay so
you guys are probably wondering what's
gonna happen with all this mac and
cheese to be honest i would have loved
to share this with friends and other
people because i just like feeding them
food unfortunately that's just not
something i can do right now and i'm
just really glad that i'm not lactose
intolerant so if excuse me i have a lot
of mac and cheese to consume
[Music]
you